das könnte ein entscheidender durchbruch
für zukünftige mars missionen seien ein
nasa forschungsteam hat jetzt nämlich
den perfekten landeplatz auf dem roten
planeten aufgespürt nur wenige
zentimeter unter der oberfläche befindet
sich hier nämlich nutzbares wasser eis
und dieser landeplatz ist gar nicht da
wo bisher große wasservorkommen vermutet
wurden klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt es täglich spannende seien sie
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocken nur dann verpasst er nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen schon in
fünf jahren 2024 sollen wieder menschen
auf den mond landen unter anderem auch
die erste frau überhaupt und das ganze
dient als eine art sprungbrett menschen
auch auf den mars zu schicken doch wo
genau auf dem roten planeten wäre ein
idealer ort zum landen
ein nasa forschungsteam hat jetzt ein
gebiet auf dem mars identifiziert das
vielversprechend ist denn hier befindet
sich ein eisspeicher nur etwa 2,5
zentimeter unter der oberfläche
klar ist was er ist eine wichtige
ressource für jede kuh die auf dem roten
planeten landen würde das eis könnte
ausgegraben werden um daraus trinkwasser
zu gewinnen aber nicht nur das auch
raketentreibstoff könnte daraus gewonnen
werden und zwar wenn wasser in
sauerstoff und wasserstoff durch
elektrolyse aufgespalten würde so könnte
die rückreise zur erde ermöglicht werden
doch auch die hinreise zum mars würde
durch einen zugang zu einem solchen
eisspeicher enorm vereinfacht werden
dazu der nasa planeten wissenschaftler
sind ein pickel wasser von der erde mit
zu bringen wäre unglaublich teuer je
weniger war mitbringen muss desto mehr
raum hat man für ein weiteres
wissenschaftliches experiment oder
zusätzliche technische mittel
dieses konzept wird unter nasa
fachleuten als in situ ressourcen
nutzung bezeichnet und ist ein sehr
wichtiger faktor um potenziellen
landeplätze zu bewerten die neue analyse
des nasa forschungsteams basiert auf
daten die die beiden raumsonden mars
reconnaissance orbiter lro und mars und
jupiter gesammelt haben solch eine
analyse basiert auf der wärme die von
der mars oberfläche aus abgestrahlt wird
denn eis leitet wärme besser als
trockener boden die wärme signatur gibt
also hinweise darauf wie tief sich das
eis unter der planetenoberfläche
befindet
solange es den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern also das eisfeld das
sehr dicht unter der oberfläche liegt
zuordnen dazu zählen pickel mit einer
harke oder einer schaufel könnte man das
ausgraben es müsste keine schwere
ausrüstung mitgebracht werden um darauf
zuzugreifen
diese erkenntnis lässt die fachleute
einen gewissen optimismus verspüren denn
die bisherigen erfahrungen mit dem mars
maulwurf der missionen inside zeigen
dass sich grabung auf dem mars
kompliziert gestalten
eigentlich sollte das instrument bis zu
fünf meter in den mars boden graben
doch es blieb nach wenigen zentimetern
stecken werden darüber hier ausführlich
zum science und fiction berichtet dass
nun geordnete gebiet erstaunt die
fachleute denn es handelt sich um eine
gegend in den mittleren breitengraden
eine wirklich spektakuläre erkenntnis
denn bislang hatte man zwar in erwägung
gezogen dass sich dort eis befinden
könnte man hatte es aber viel tiefer
vermutet konkret handelt es sich um ein
gebiet mit der bezeichnung ak der planie
zia eine ebene in den mittleren breiten
der nordhalbkugel diese tiefebene liegt
nordwestlich der tages vulkanregion und
ist von resten alter lavaströme bedeckt
den neuen erkenntnissen zufolge liegt
das wassereis hier stellenweise weniger
als 30 zentimeter tief und teilweise
sogar eben nur wenige zentimeter unter
der oberfläche und wird von lockerem
material bedeckt was einfach auszugeben
während dieser ort ist nach ansicht der
expertinnen und experten also besonders
für eine landung oder sogar eine
messstation geeignet dass der rote
planet an seinen polen über sehr viel
über flächen als verfügt das ist schon
seit längerer zeit bekannt dennoch sind
diese gegen einen keineswegs ein guter
landeort denn hier herrschen viele
monate extreme kälte und dunkelheit
ebenso ungeeignet ist der äquator das
maß denn hier ist es wohl zu warm für
eis die dünne atmosphäre des roten
planeten verhindert es dass flüssiges
wasser existieren könnte
das eis wird also durch das erwärmen
nicht zunächst flüssig sondern verdampft
direkt das forschungsteam schreibt in
seiner aktuellen studie unsere
ergebnisse bestätigen dass es bis 35
grad nord und 55 grad süd weit
verbreitet sind das wasser es gibt
teilweise nur wenige zentimeter unter
sand artigen material die nasa fachleute
wollen das gebiet jetzt noch genauer
erkunden und konkrete landeplätze
genauer ins visier
wir nehmen hier sollen vor allem auf die
sicherheit der zukünftigen maß
astronautinnen und astronauten großer
wert gelegt werden doch bei der auswahl
des perfekten landeplatzes achten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
auch darauf dass die oberfläche gut
untersucht werden kann dazu das
forschungsteam wir sammeln weiter daten
über das auf dem mars verborgene eis und
hoffen so die besten landeplätze für
künftige astronauten noch weiter
einzugrenzen fünf fakten übermaß und
zwar ziemlich spektakuläre gibt es hier
dieses wirklich ziemlich coole
animations- video von astro comics tv
anklicken anschauen und astro comics tv
natürlich abonnieren oder bis dann
bleibt dran